[موسيقى]
خلال شهر رمضان يحيي المسلمون من شتى بقاع
الارض سنه الاعتكاف داخل المسجد الحرام
[موسيقى]
2500 معتكف بموسم رمضان هذا العام وفرت
لهم رئاسه شؤون الحرمين المصليات والبرامج
الدينيه والتوعويه وكافه الخدمه بمقدمتها
سقيا زمزم ووجبات الافطار والسحور اضافه
الى عياده طبيه وغيرها
للمعتكفين حزمه من الخدمات من ضمنها تهيئه
المكان المناسب
لكي يقوم المعتكف بعباده الاعتكاف في جو
ايماني وبكل يسر وسهوله ومن ضمنها توفير
خزانات للمعتكفين توضع بها اغراضهم
الشخصيه التي يحتاجونها خلال فتره
اعتكافهم في موسم استثنائي تفيدو الى
الحرم المكي اعداد مليونيه منذ مطلع شهر
رمضان وذلك بعد فتح المسجد بكامل الطاقه
الاستيعابيه ما جعل الجهات المعنيه تكثف
خدماتها وبرامجها للتسهيل على المعتمرين
والمصلين من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه